So I'm in the car with my husband,
and I'm talking about the comments that I've been receiving
on a lot of the content that I've posted recently
about what's going on in Gaza
with Operation Olive Branch, etcetera.
And a comment that I've gotten a couple times from Jewish,
other Jewish people
are that I haven't spoken up in strong support of the hostages.
And when I really sit back and think about it,
they're 100% correct,
I haven't. And as we go forward with these conversations on my page,
100% of the reason that I haven't is for two reasons.
One, because the way the internet is handling this,
if you speak out about one group of people,
regardless of if they are innocent civilians on either side,
you are somehow
aligning your allegiance with only one side of this conflict,
with the civilians on one side of this conflict.
Number two is blanket fear.
And if you are a Jewish person,
you will understand this like generational trauma,
this trigger of fear of antisemitism.
And while I have been unpacking everything that's been going on
and learning a lot more about the issue,
the one thing that I've held firm in my belief,
in my heart,
deeply empathize and care about the civilians on both sides.
And I should have spoken about the hostages sooner,
because there is absolutely nothing anybody can say
that could justify to me
stealing children out of their beds,
taking young people celebrating At a music festival. Hostage.
Civilians are not culpable in the actions of their government.
Any action against civilians for a political gain is terrorism.
It just is.
Which is why I don't support the blanket retaliation on Palestine
from Israel either.
When October 7th happened,
I, like,
looked leapfrogged into the future on how this was gonna look,
and I knew that this was gonna come down to, like,
good Jew, bad Jew.
My fear of that has kept me from speaking out against, um,
the taking of hostages.
And my fear of the team mentality on all of this
has kept me from speaking about the people in Gaza at length
as well. And I'm kind of over that,
because in reality,
if you care about civilian life,
you care about it on both sides.
And I will help in the ways that I can,
the people that I can.
But I truly believe that until, as a global society,
we can get to a point where human life matters more than
religion and politics,
we're just gonna repeat this cycle over and over.